all right we're gonna live it says we're
gonna live don't live it says we are
live okay awesome
hello and welcome to round table with
the stream team this is where we talk to
content creators about their journeys
and where they are today I would like to
welcome to the roundtable Martian Kat
tonight's our table how are you doing
tonight I'm pretty good thanks for
having me
fantastic company here so we have a
couple of other you know roundtable
members here today we have MJ as a boss
what's mom and how yeah we have miss
boogie good afternoon how you doing
fantastic you're doing good all is good
yep pretty good
all right cool cool all right and well
we have mr. old-school-style who is uh
mi a so I'm hoping he is just past that
right now sleeping so we can only hope
so now while we are all here today
Martian cat so tell us about why you
decided to become a content creator well
I would say I'm kind of an accidental
streamer I don't even know what twitch
was when I got on there a friend of mine
had you know I started to play dining
light and a friend wanted to see the
game play so I was like oh okay he's
like yeah you get on this site and do
all this other stuff so like all right
I'll do it
you know and people started showing up
and asking me questions about the game
so it's kind of like alright well this
is kind of cool other people
they want to watch me play a game
alright you know yeah yeah is so it's
kind of like one of those just happen to
walk into a type situations
yeah was you know once I got into it and
and understood how it worked and you
know what could happen because of it I
was like oh you know what I'm actually
interested in this you know and I want
to learn more about it the social media
aspects of it which really
fascinate me mm-hmm so yeah it was just
it was easy to pick up after I started
to figure it all out
haha so you when you originally started
to to stream you ended up starting from
your xbox your PC where did you end up
starting I started streaming from my PC
my computer really couldn't even handle
streaming and the games that I was
playing so I actually crashed a lot
until I upgraded
nobody told me that you need a you know
better graphics card to do all this
stuff to learn as I went yeah yeah
that's that's oohs um the little bump in
the road so almost everyone that starts
streaming they say oh I wanna start
streaming and then if they're on like
Xbox or Playstation it's usually not too
bad but like when that when PC people
start they was like oh I'm just gonna
install OBS on my computer and then the
next thing they know there's like oh man
why is my computer keep crashing why
does he keep dying why am i moving three
like frames a second so I full I fully
get you with that one
so shout out to pain and the chat she
says hi cat
ain't you says hi cat so your first game
is you ended up laying dying right then
is that the first one you decided to
kind of cast your twitch you know yes
yeah it started out with dying light and
I still play it I still had not dying
light I don't still play that but I also
played Star Wars The Old Republic and
that's where I started actually gaining
my following is my place with Gore so oh
absolutely I'll bring on the onslaught
I'm ready for that ready to go I
literally just got goosebumps thinking
about Star Wars because you have
obviously we got fallen fallen were
coming I the way you're talking it
sounds like you're a huge Star Wars buff
am I am I correct
oh yeah I I'm a huge Star Wars fan also
a huge I also play so tour on the PC and
well I love it I think it's one of the
best games that right
most other MMOs and people kind of push
it to the side like it's not that good
but it really is that good oh absolutely
it's a it's a completely underrated MMO
you know and usually the reaction I get
from people when I say you know I play
so tours it's like oh my god putting out
content what are you talking about you
know because because you're such an avid
player of that game how did you feel
when they changed it to the chapter
system oh when they when they switched
over to doing chapters for the
expansions yeah yeah cuz I cuz I have an
opinion well I'll be first I think the
first time that I noticed it was the
what is it the lost Empire or the that
one I thought it was a little bit
irritating because you're almost stuck
in the chapters and you can't get out
yeah you know it's like well wait a
minute so now my characters stuck
playing these chapters lost all their
companions I can't play with my friends
because I can't log out of this oh yeah
no I was not happy with that at all yeah
I felt first similar to you with that I
was just like what am I gonna do now I
have to I have to finish this so it
almost it was like I had to say okay
this chapter comes out I have to sit
there grind it finish it next won't come
out next month trying that finish it and
then keep going and it kind of got it
got annoying because the game has got so
much potential but they literally are
putting it behind a paywall
to the to the point where I actually
would I wouldn't play until all the
chapters came out then sub for one month
play all the chapters and then unsub it
or do whatever I want else I wanted to
do yeah a lot of people do that night
and I feel that they're really doing
themselves a disservice by locking all
the expansions behind the paywall you
know when you trying to get new players
in or like oh hey it's free-to-play you
can make X amount of characters you can
do all this stuff but they're you know
when you're trying to get people to play
most of the time they want a team with
you for the expansions with play because
they're free
so you know then you're then you're
stuck telling them oh well if you just
buy something from the cartel market you
can get that yes no nobody wants to hear
that when you just said it was free to
play come on
yeah well I think that what they ended
up doing with the with the cartel market
with a lot of like the special gear you
have and the crystals you have and the
weapons and the gear you have I thought
that was cool but it almost came to the
point where you had to it was like
almost like a pay2win type situation
which I was kind of a little little sad
about because I said what I wanted to
play a game and grind I want to get cool
gear or I want to do this in that I kind
of felt like it was it was like you just
have to buy the cool stuff yeah I could
agree with that you know it's like all
right you see that there's a lot of gear
that you can buy that will make your
character look dope level one you know
look like a darts at level one he's got
a grind for that gear you know exactly
I assume you're excited for the movie at
the end of the year oh absolutely
[Music]
trailer out tonight yeah yeah so
probably probably within the next 30 40
minutes so by the time we finish this
we're all watch the trailer stop this
and watch the trailer and it's already
got tickets my sister-in-law is a huge
Star Wars fan also so what we usually
end up doing is it's like that week
between Christmas and New Year's I take
off from work so we just go my my
brother myself my wife and my sister on
all four of us we'll just go to one of
the really nice movie theaters and like
the
morning and we just go when we watch it
together because I mean me and my
sister-in-law will just be sitting there
with our eyes like this looking at the
screen the whole time like just like I
got a I got a what what's happening
what's happening and that's that's what
we usually end up doing but are you are
you gonna be playing for an order also
uh I am on the fence I'm on the fence
about it I
I like the multiplayer game but you know
I just like having that option and I
also I'm a little bit upset that they're
making it strictly light side choice and
I'm not I'm not down with that I like to
have the option to either go light or
dark side did you play did you play the
one star killer in it yes for something
yes I love that was really cool but you
know your skill tree was very important
you get back to that boss fight at the
end of the game and if your uh your
skill tree wasn't hit you know right
you're in trouble you're not you're not
taking down Palpatine yeah yeah I'm kind
of excited to see what they're gonna end
up doing cuz I'm like you I was a big
fan of those those games also so I'm
kind of quite across with my fingers of
waiting to see what happens
so I'm gonna I'm gonna be there day one
playing that I've probably there's
probably a few people that have been
into Star Wars land as much as I have
since it happened i I keep seeing your
pictures on Instagram yeah and I just I
get serious because and then so when I
went to d23 did you see my like special
edition Boba Fett hat no they like put
the b23 of the year and everything on
the side so it's like special no one
else has oh my god alright up later yeah
like we're done I was like so oh my god
it was so amazing d23 was probably the
crescendo of my like Star Wars
experience so far
it's like seeing all these suits and
everything and like they're right there
funny you look just as shiny as they
look in the movies and everything and
it's just like like all I need is for
you guys to just hop down and start
acting pretty excited because next year
my husband I were going to Star Wars
Celebration in that way he said he's
going down to galaxies Ange this summer
and he said you psyched do you have any
gaming Vivek games
did you ever the advice Joe any advice
when you go well I went is he going to
the one that's in Florida Florida
haven't been there ever do in Florida
you going to the one in California I
want to go to the one in Florida but I
want to go to that one too I am like I
am worried that it's gonna be packed
well you know it's gonna be back like I
I don't I don't like sitting on mines
for a really long time which I know I
will be okay so don't go to Disneyworld
oh no me and me and my wife when we went
down to Disney in May the lines were not
bad we went it we also we also got hit
with the a lot of oh it was really
really hot we had record highs it was
like a hundred and ten down there and in
May we were dying that's why nobody was
there it was nobody was there but you
know what like we went on a couple of
rides like we were getting nauseous and
sick from dehydration
almost every we were going to ride and I
would wait 20 minutes and then go on
another ride it was crazy
dead that game said he's going to one in
California okay so that was like you're
lucky because they just put out they're
gonna be changing some of the food
because the food really sucked there I
was really upset with how bad the food
was because Disney on a whole has been
like taking their food eNOS to a whole
new level in California I don't know how
it is in Florida but it's like they have
the Food and Wine Festival twice a year
on the California mistress all right
like they're starting to get you know
they're starting to make their food good
because one of the things about going to
Disney I was always you know food sir
but yeah Eman be prepared to spend money
like if you want a real-life lightsaber
it's 200 bucks you know it looks like
it's like a replica of whatever one that
was in the movie
so yeah and if you want a cheapy one
they're like 40 50 bucks something like
that because I got a bb-8 made there
build a droid that's cold that's awesome
yeah like actually like put it together
and then it does this little sequence to
let it know that it's synced to you it's
pretty cool oh that's awesome
okay yeah John what happened
I said cat a cat you haven't gone I
thought you I thought you it takes a lot
of work for me to get to California
because I live in Phoenix Arizona so
okay yeah no it should be easier for you
and this guy right here he's like closer
to the East Coast
oh yeah yeah well probably try to make
that work when we come out there for the
celebration next year yeah oh you gotta
do it go do it you have to so let let's
now talk about you as a content creator
because we'll sit here to talk about
Star Wars for an hour and I don't have a
problem so you you've been streaming and
you stream how often I strange usually I
do about three hours a week three to
four hours of stream okay three days a
week three to four hours a stream I just
we played that in my mom do you have set
days do you kind of kind of random or
when I first started I I did it when I
would come home from work because I
worked late night so I was I was
streaming like five nights a week but I
had to cut back on that when I started
working a morning shift so now I just do
Mondays Wednesdays and Saturdays so I'm
sorry oh and it's still after I get home
from work so yeah so do you do anything
else other than just those couple days
of streaming well I generally will play
games other
days a week when I'm not streaming and I
play you know I'd actually am honest
another stream and it's a role-playing
game and I do that on another night when
I'm not streaming Thursday's nice like a
Dean day or something like that yes yes
yeah yeah me and my wife we were part of
a D&D campaign also we don't stream it
either but we try to get together once a
month which as of late it's been a
little crazy since we there's a total of
six of us and two of them just moved to
believe it just moved to Vegas so it's
very hard for us to kind of get with
them to kind of you know organize
everything but I feel like though having
D&D is kind of something that I play it
makes me enjoy like role-playing games
more do do you feel that way playing
table if tabletop enhances the roleplay
experience yeah I would say so you know
it does when you're creating your own
character and really kind of forces you
to think more cream
you got all these new random people add
me on Twitter can you guys hear me yeah
you sound better
am I better yep yes what the heck just
happened what shenanigans is this I
don't know
Oh someone's gonna be getting a nasty
phone call later I also want to know why
my internet speed has been it's been
destroyed but anyway that's all the
discussion for another time
all right if you can hear me yeah all
right I guess let's see here this is
going we're still we're still alive okay
I deeply apologize because apparently
the internet gods do not want me to be
online right now so where were we we
were talking about tabletop role-playing
games and how that might inform other
aspects of games oh yeah um the game
that I get to play in with well my
husband runs it and so he and he streams
it so I get to play in that so it's kind
of nice cuz it you know it gives us a
chance be a chance to you know hang out
with him and show him the Hobby right
okay so he also streams so but yeah it's
it's a good time and I like I love I
love to role plan I've done that in many
you know of writing and playing
role-playing games and tabletop and all
that stuff so excellent so when you when
you start streaming like when how did it
kind of like affect your family as a
whole like it was were they like very
much
you know accepting to you wanting to do
this on a regular basis to put yourself
on the internet or how was it for you
um it it wasn't an issue you know I had
when I started doing it you know my my
husband I were working completely
opposite schedules so it wasn't
affecting you know really wasn't
affecting him very much because I was on
at night but he you know of course he
knew about it and he was actually
interested in it and interested in it
enough that he decided to start doing it
he's been very super supportive of me
doing the streaming and everything else
and my family even you know my family
may not understand what I'm doing yeah
but they're like well as long as you
like it that's cool yeah this is
fantastic
do you do you feel like you are starting
to accomplish your your goal when it
comes to streaming like you with their
growth with the with your happiness with
your teen with your community things
like that yes I didn't have any you know
particular goals in mind when I had
first started to stream I think it
really kind of hit me that there was
something to it when affiliate came out
for for a twitch mm-hmm and it was like
oh well hit these goals and then you can
start to make some money you know not
that I was expecting to make you know
ridiculous amounts of money you know
it's like I work this is a hobby but it
was kind of like wow okay there's enough
people watching me that I had hit that
within I think I was in the second round
of people who had gotten invited mm-hmm
so after that I really kind of started
paying attention to one my numbers and
to the type of community and chat that I
wanted to build around myself you talk
about like you do after once the
affiliate kind of came out you started
checking out the the analytics portion
of the of that side of streaming yes
yeah I would say before that I didn't
really pay attention to it you know I
just had what you know whatever you know
whatever friends that were on Twitter
you know who saw my my posts you know
like whole hey I'm going live right now
you know and it went from those just
those folks hanging out in the chat to
people that I didn't even know it was
like whoa okay there are more people
outside of say my little circle of
internet friends who are actually
interested in what I'm doing and want to
see
that's cool right that's awesome do you
um is there a reason why you
specifically picked twitch over mixer at
the time a mixer was the other site at
the time when I started on twitch um I
felt that oh my gosh I don't remember
what it was called before mixer now just
beam pinging that's right that's right I
didn't know very much about that and the
discussion around it was just that it
was mostly for people who were on
console and I didn't get I didn't get
even get an Xbox one or ps4 until well
after I started streaming on Twitch
mm-hmm yeah when a lot of people when
when they asked me that because because
of how I regularly streamed a there was
go oh why are you why did you go to it
why didn't you pick mixer and they told
us other you know almost like not a
controversial conversation but it's more
like oh why didn't you pick this over
this I don't understand it like you know
this is so much better this has got all
these like latency and all these other
things and and kind of my answer has
always been
I felt like more comfortable and how I
have already started growing my
community and I already have a lot of
friends and a lot of you know Network
people that I speak to on the twitch
side that if I go over to mixer I feel
like I'm gonna I'm gonna lose all that
that's why I kind of I've always stayed
away from that that's that's that's how
I kind of I felt you know and with with
that whole type of controversial
conversation so to speak right I had
attempted to stream on well after it was
already mixer at that time when I had
gotten my xbox and I tried to stream on
there a couple of times and it just I
don't know I liked this I like the speed
of the chat that was cold it was like
almost you know instantaneous you know
alright somebody typed something kaboom
it's right there yeah I did like that I
also felt that the community was fairly
friendly twitch just camp you know
twitch
be really tough you know it's like
Showtime at the Apollo folks are
hardcore over there on Twitch
and if somebody don't like you they're
all over you you know and mixer folks
tend to give each other a little more
chance you know yeah
so I did try try the other service you
know um I have an account like on
caffeine but I've never attempted to
stream over there yeah but I
by the time mixer had rebranded itself
you know from beamed a mixer I had
already had a I'm you know I say sizable
but it's like I already had a following
mm-hmm and to just drop all that to go
over to mixer really would have just I
think what it's completely stalled my
growth that's just my opinion I know
there are there are other people who
have had you know who had roughly around
the same numbers in it and move to mixer
and have found success over there or
found their idea of success over there
and that's fantastic that's great
but I figure you know name recognition
for twitch why why move now yeah you
know three years into it why move now
you know yeah that's that's that's kind
of somewhere how I feel like I I mean ah
I think that's what that's that's how I
feel like the whole entire transition is
for a lot of people like wouldn't what
ninja ended up doing with this
transition over to mixer I feel like is
not the norm because he had pretty much
backing from Microsoft in the publicity
to kind of pull everybody over I mean if
I told people hey I'm gonna be moving
from twitch to mixer I'm not gonna be
telling people they're getting it free
subscriptions to come over to my channel
and I think that he kind of was the it
was not the norm oh absolutely you know
if you are if you don't have a name
recognition like he does absolutely not
you're gonna start square one mm-hmm you
were talking about the growth of your
channel like what like what do you feel
is like you're number one you know
necessary thing to have to allow your
channel to grow I think one of the the
key I don't want to see like the keys to
success cuz that's really not
but the thing that I think draws people
at least to my channel my mods get out
that's one of my mods in the chat being
being a troll and I would say that it's
it's it's strictly my community there's
a lot of people when I go into their
channels and when they're doing like
shoutouts and stuff they'll talk about
how nice my my chat is you know and that
my dad is this world chill and I think
that was kind of the thing that I wanted
most was you know low tolerance for
trolls you know and just relax chat and
just be cool about it you know and I
kind of feel like that has driven driven
my my numbers up and I appreciate that
that's really cool you know that folks
are like all right you know we know that
this is gonna be you know like low to no
drama and they want to come and hang out
for that and I think that's great yeah
that's I agree I agree that I think that
having you know that enjoyable
atmosphere is what's gonna keep bringing
those people and and that's that's
exactly what I would think do you have a
first time that you can think of when
you do like a couch type gaming co-op
situation with like family friends like
that that first gaming experience do you
remember what it was uh my first co-op
stream well a little nut stream I'm
talking like in general like oh yeah in
general that's not just dreaming okay
well my first major memory of play
playing games with other people would
definitely be with my brothers playing
Nintendo back when I was a kid you know
we every buddy would go and you don't
rent those video games from the local
video store yeah it's kind of showing my
age there um you know and we would just
hang out and you know play on the
Nintendo all weekend and then you know
the Genesis and so on you know or go to
the arcade did that a lot yeah
I think I think it's a lot it's a lost
like feeling a lost art like these I
hate to wear it this way because MJ
probably doesn't know these kids
nowadays they never have that experience
of like your mother going shopping at a
mall and you're like I don't want to go
shopping at a mall so I'm gonna go to
the arcade down down on the corner and
then you and the blood playing Street
Fighter for like three hours with
quarters because you don't want to be
sitting there watching your mother try
on clothes for hours on end
absolutely absolutely that's my
experience anyway after school that was
that that was a lot of fun you know
Mortal Kombat had just came out and man
we would crowd around that box at the
7-eleven play that for a couple hours
after school you know yeah like King he
has a that that big arcade machine with
all those old vintage video games on it
oh it's so it's so beautiful and I I
think it's a full cabinet I I gotta get
the link from him but like he he has a
full cabinet and he's always like shows
videos and stuff like that on it's
pretty amazing that's awesome so are you
are you planning on trying to hit up any
conventions or anything this year I
actually did do a couple of conventions
most of most of the Commission's I go to
our local just cuz I don't like to fly
so I don't travel too far I've got you
know one of the things that I I also
attribute to you know streaming is being
able to do panels which I've done for
the past couple years here locally in
Phoenix you know just getting to talk
about you know being a woman in gaming
talk about my experiences as a streamer
just kind of like what we're doing right
now but you know to do that
you know those I've I've done those for
the past couple years and it's a lot of
fun yeah so how so how often are you on
the on panels on the panels for for
yourself and which ones and which ones
what if you don't mind saying which ones
they are
well the last panel that I did was it
was women and gaming and streaming and I
got to do that at well it's called the
Phoenix fan fusion but basically it's
the Phoenix Comic Con oh who are cool
yeah and I got to do that there and
that's basically the panel that I've
been on I've done just that one and I
did it at Comic Con last year I did it
this year as well also at a convention
called Sabaton which is a Japanese pop
culture convention here in Phoenix on
Labor Day weekend and I got to do that I
didn't get to do it this year just
because I had things going on mm-hmm
yeah they're a lot of fun to do and it's
kind of trippy to get recognized out in
public
no that's kind of a weird experience you
know but that's also kind of neat too
well you've got you kind of just walking
around and someone's like oh and I know
that's cat over there you know like I
can see how that's kind of a kind of a
little weird situation yeah it's kind of
startling you know we were we were on
our way to the you know to the today
we're going to a hotel my husband and I
for the convention because we you know
rather stay close to the Convention
Center and we're walking through the
lobby and stuff and all of a sudden I
hear Martian cat and I'm like what
that's branding me as a streamer nothing
I'm just walking around my husband and
folks recognized me just walking through
the lobby I'm like okay Wow please
please tell me you did a little like you
know session and you'd be like oh look
at me I'm the celebrity it just tripped
me out you know I wasn't I wasn't
expecting that but yeah it was it was a
wild experience I know that other folks
probably have that too it's like wait a
minute
who y'all know who I am okay hey and how
did you do when you were at the
conventions like you said one was like
the Japanese anime convention of some
sort yeah are you a fan of anime at all
there no I am like some anime my my
friends my friends and my community are
trying to get me to turn around and
really
I'm a bigger anime fan you know I'm
working on it they're there they're
there wearing me down if you if you need
suggestions hit me up I will give you a
list I probably have a list of probably
about 40 or 50 that I've liked series of
shows that I've ended up watching and
this isn't even a joke this is me being
serious like I have right now I am
consistently weekly watch 10 different
animes because I want to make sure that
I can get as many as I can to watch
because I feel like cartoons now are not
like when we were younger and now now
anime has almost turned into what our
cartoons were so it's almost like
they've transitioned to more of like an
older type of anime type situation yeah
it seems like that it's it's bad
animation now I really can't get into it
I just a little too much for me that was
actually pretty cool I've watched it a
couple times not enough to like know who
the characters are but you know I
watched a couple episodes it wasn't bad
I also have a 9 year old but I don't
know like I'll watch that with her and
then there was another one I was on
Disney about twins I don't know why I
can't remember right now but it was
basically like all the voices were
comedians that we all probably loved you
know so it was like easy to get into the
cartoon because you could they're making
jokes that were really for us you know
the adult shows yeah
gravity falls oh yeah okay I do not have
children so I am unsure of these
childish children's well you should
still be allowed to turn on Disney yeah
I also need cable for that so
you know I have Disney clothes I went to
d23 I got three years I know I know I
just you I'd you - I actually got mine t
- I got mine so November 15th right I
think it is I'm all over that business I
can't wait I'm sorry Lauren yes I'm
going to binge watch that and I will be
until the end
okay I'm sorry to like not talk about
gaming did anybody watch Watchmen well
listen I see it's is it gonna be on
Disney Plus well Watchmen is on HBO it's
really that probably why I don't own HBO
I've never seen Game of Thrones so that
wasn't for them you know the only thing
I want to see on HBO is Silicon Valley
yeah that watch the last season though
that is supposed to be a very very funny
TV show yeah the first couple of seasons
were really hilarious
ah so let's get let's get back on course
here cuz obvious obviously tangents are
always a plus for us here so Kat when
you what do you consider yourself do you
consider yourself like a variety
streamer yes I would say that I'm a
variety streamer but I focused mostly on
story heavy games either single or
multiplayer but one of the things I tell
people is I really love games that are
heavy on story most of those happen to
be shooters really well with shooters
would you say dying lights a shooter
divisions the shooter I played The Last
of Us that's a shooter you know so all
games that are true story but I have
never played Uncharted I've I have not
either
I would say yes that's a tutor and it
also has you know a pretty good story
from what I've heard yeah my brother my
brother has the PlayStation 3 which no
longer works but I wanted to grab it
from him and start playing all of the
Uncharted series he has Amol and
eventually I was you know hopefully when
the PS 5 comes out I'll pick up a PS 5
and then go back for a whole bunch of
games that I've been missing but oh yes
yeah the Bioshock came up in the chat
Bioshock is my all-time favorite game
my whole my favorite series of games the
whole franchise absolutely and I'm then
we you know a friend of mine and I were
like take it making it our point to
harass the developers into another game
hopefully they will listen to us at some
point I wish I wish
old school was here because he actually
streamed the whole entire all of the
Bioshock games and he posted a lot of it
up on his YouTube channel cuz he loves
he loves it so much I wish she was here
oh yeah and I and I played that DLC for
infinite for about 4 BioShock Infinite
yes yeah if anybody hasn't played the
BioShock Infinite DLC I highly recommend
doing so so you you playing first-person
shooters and you said you play the
division did you how much did you love
the the first one and then kind of like
arcing into the second one was it kind
of how did you feel I
I played the division during beta that
was though that was what sold me on the
game the the initial plot and the
gameplay you know the squad based
gameplay I really liked that it did
become a little repetitive after a while
though I thought that they missed a lot
of opportunities
for expanding the story by not adding
story content to say the underground
mm-hmm or adding story missions to the
dark zone things that the dark zone is
still without a lot of story
even in Div - which is also
disappointing so I know that it's
possibly the PvP area but it could have
some story missions do you want to bring
some people in here right
but Dib - has definitely improved a lot
of the gameplay over the first game you
know the NPC's not being you know
incredibly useless as they were in the
first yes is a big big change yes yeah
and simplifying the equipment and the
skill tree that you know that's a big
thing to do so have you have you played
it since the last week since I did title
update 6 I have I soloed the Pentagon on
Saturday which was a lot of fun yeah I
love that expedition content that's
great
yeah the expeditions are pretty neat
with the end up doing I really like that
how they added those I love how they're
improving the the content of the game
they're making it grow
most people know I'm a huge division
franchise IP fan because like I mean I
have I've over over 400 hours and if one
I have over 400 hours and if two already
so I mean I I'm one of those people that
play it non-stop and I still do every
Friday with my rating just because it's
it's fun to you know you know flash bang
your friends out of nowhere so you know
we do stuff like that all the time but I
kind of agree with you with what they
ended up doing I think that what a lot
of people I will take it back a step I
think that a lot of the content creators
for div 2 are very very hostile
individuals and I think that's kind of
hurting them as a group and I think that
the
the content that they're adding and the
things that they're putting into div too
is gonna make it such a good game and I
think that what they're gonna what
they're gonna need to end up doing is in
the future is kind of add more content
faster because once they end up saying
that the next rate isn't going to be
coming out until next year it's gonna
really really hurt the people in the
player base and it it might be the nail
in the coffin if they end up pushing it
off that long I feel like yeah and I
thought there was some you know fury on
Twitter about you know just the the
fandom I don't know what's going on with
that I I don't participate in the drama
Rama as I don't do it you know I love
the game for the game I don't you know I
don't care about the PvP content I know
a lot of people do I don't I just care
about the story and I care about the
gameplay that goes along with it that's
really it for me
yeah and the story can't the story
concept that they're doing is fantastic
I really like the story that would it's
one of those things being a New Yorker
and seeing how it kind of affected New
York like the dollar flew with not whole
situation and then it kind of
progressing and then going into you know
into DC and how that's kind of evolving
and we all know what episode three is
going to be which is they're going to
come back to New York
which is going to be really really you
know interesting to see because they're
coming back to Coney Island and I'm
super pumped to see it super pop I hope
that it catches on but afraid about it i
we had started a hashtag keener must die
and it's it's gotta have it it's it's
gonna happen it they may end up then
more than likely they're probably in
development for a division three more
more than likely it's happening but
they're we gotta go after him at some
point
so I'm sitting here yapping did L MJ you
guys you guys have any questions with
anything going on
not about the division well general you
guys I'm sorry do we could talk about
destiny
do you play destiny I I police say the
story once and then I got a little bit
miffed when they were talking about that
first expansion and you had to pay for
it again and I'm like say what now
get on down the road with that I stopped
playing right after that so you you were
saying before that you have people that
come in and out of your chat
consistently right um do you think and
sometimes you do get have the hateful
people that come into your chat the kind
of caused problems at all how do you
kind of deal with them if that does
happen yeah I have been very very
fortunate to have a very minimal very
minimal troll problem yeah I don't know
if that's because they kind of come in
and see that I'm not about that yeah you
know and kind of move on or what I've
had experiences where people have
attempted to troll and it's like okay
look you can either see yourself out or
I will see you out
yeah and generally they'll just leave I
very rarely have had to ban people knock
on wood for that and you know and I
handled things in my own way I get weird
questions that's what I get I don't get
so much people being like hateful and
horrible but I get strange trolli
questions no all right what well one of
the last questions that that I had
gotten was about two there were two
instances one somebody came in and was
like how tall are you
I'm sorry what you know so you know he's
like oh you know how tall are you down
and I'm like why are you asking me how
tall I am I just want to know it's like
well why are you like why are you asking
me that is there some type of you know
scavenger hunt to ask different
streamers health
all they are you know and after that he
got real quiet you know but I thought it
was very funny and and the other
incident that I had
oh are you married yeah that was
acquaintances yeah this was a couple of
weeks ago matter-of-fact and there was
like well are you married and I'm like
what does that have to do with anything
no it's like why do you want to know
like what do you care you know well I'm
asking everybody that and they're
recommended okay that's an odd question
well I usually get banned for that I
said well I'm not gonna ban you for
asking me if I'm married but I'm not
about to come out here and tell you that
either I mean I am but what you know
strange at some at some point you have
to think to yourself there there's a
line and yeah it's like when at one
point are you gonna realize that you
know like streamers are people you know
and you know they're just like you and I
and if you we're gonna go to like talk
to like a fly calf rend or somebody
you're gonna treat them with respect you
don't want to do the scene like it it
just it doesn't make sense like I can't
believe someone would ask that silly
ridiculous question yeah it's like and I
guess they were expecting to get banned
because they made the comment well I
usually get banned for that it's like
okay this is a pointless question I
don't get which where you're most
females automatically ban them because
they don't even want to deal with what's
gonna come after exactly and that was
what you know myself and one of my mods
it said it's like it's a leading
question right that mean leading and we
just ignored it and I can you know it's
like okay whatever stay if you want cuz
you're giving me the view thank you no I
know that one of one of my friends
respawn he was he was on the
cast on he said that he's had a lot of
people notoriously come into his chat to
be to pretty much be trolls to just
pretty much because and I teased him
about this all the time he looks like a
hippie from Williamsburg like he's got
the he's got the man bun he's got the
big ginormous beard he straight-up looks
like a hippie and like people go in
there all the time just trying to troll
them and he ends up turning all of his
trolls into like subs and viewers I
don't know how he does it like
consistently all the time but it's just
it happens so some of these trolls you
know like I don't deal with them but
yeah like I feel like you never know
what you're gonna get with them that's
true you know I I have some friends who
stream that absolutely feed on it they
love trolling the trolls you know and
we'll invite them in you know I just
have like zero tolerance for that type
of stuff
even though and and I think part of that
to you is also how the streamer portrays
themselves if they are somebody who at
least this just my experience with my
friends is that you know one of the
things is that they're usually very
aggressive when they're playing their
games they're you know they talk a lot
of trash and so people come in and
they're talking a lot of trash and
that's how this all goes about you know
I don't do that even in multiplayer
games I try to keep it real chill and
low-key even though I ain't gonna lie
when I'm not on my stream I'm rowdy Oh
get out come on stream I'm not so you
know I think that I think that really
sets the tone you know for what's gonna
happen in your chat oh yeah I really
think it does it makes a difference um
right actually brought he said something
that kind of made me kind of trigger in
my head a question for you oh when you
when you play with your community do you
like require a some type of level of
commitment to them
do you like require them to be subs do
you require them to be followers or you
do only stream with people that you know
could be safe in your in your in your
stream for with communications okay
if it is somebody who I'm not familiar
with if it's a viewer that I haven't you
know seen before or anything like that
I'll usually will just tell them like
look you know I generally just play with
people I know I'm sorry you know there's
a good a couple times when I've gotten
pretty burnt by that you know I'll let
somebody in
not to voice chat if I don't know them
but you know this person kind of pushed
their way into my division game you know
they found me on you play and popped
into my game and it was like whoa hey
you know like wait a minute
inviting you but you're here now so
let's just play the game yeah you know
and he proceeded to be a little bit
strange and weird so I ended up you know
bouncing bouncing them out it will work
out but generally I just played with my
friends you know sub required
none of that stuff so yeah I end the
plan like I'm saying with the creeper
guys on on Friday nights and and
throughout the week really and I tell
people I was like if if I'm if I'm
playing the game expects me to be
streaming if you are out of line I'm
pulling you out of the channel I don't
care because like you know this is you
know these these are people watching for
a certain reason they're not here to
hear you like ridiculously curse run
your mouth and think you're you know the
coolest thing since sliced bread
so like that's that's why I like I've
I've always felt that if you like are
strict with those people or you have
like guidelines like you have guidelines
it works out really well and it benefits
you more than more than most people yeah
yeah that's true you know I like to play
with folks that are as you know big
goofball as I am I love to laugh in my
chat it's ridiculous I'm cracking up all
the time and my the folks that I play
with even if it's just a you know like
viewers and stuff they'll if they vibe
with me on like that and we're cracking
each other up and it's usually really
good you kind of don't have time to be
trash-talking when you're cracking up so
yeah or try to make each other laugh and
that's another thing too I've been
broken
by my friends on stream more than once
like crying laughing I'm losing my
breath and it's bad yeah and I love that
I think those make for some of the best
moments in stream you know when use when
you stream do you come like you are you
would you call yourself or do you have
to kind of like put on a little persona
or is it kind of like just like so
people kind of can relate to that or are
you or are you like what you see is what
you get type of person when you stream
um I think I about the only thing that I
really change about me when I'm on the
stream versus when I'm not is my
language bad mouth when I'm not online
so I do kind of temper that cuz you know
it's like alright I don't know who's
gonna be watching you know and that also
can hurt hurt potential for other things
when folks do that so I tried try to
keep it keep it contained and I think
there's you know I I have I don't know
it don't really call it a persona but I
do kind of portray this ideal that I'm
an alien just in the human suit so you
know and I think we all feel that way
and that's kind of the vibe that I give
off is I always tell them hey we're all
Martians here we're all aliens and this
weird thing we call life and if that's
something that folks can get down with
and be respectful of each other be
respectful of me and they could stay in
the chat and they can hang out gotcha oh
yeah I I happen to be looking at your
your Facebook page and not face what I'm
sorry Twitter page and I happened to see
that you had you were part of a couple
of different groups and I was just I was
hoping you can kind of elaborate on them
one of them was red planet brigade and
the other one was the cookout right
the red planet brigade is the community
that had basically sprung up from my
stream because I'm a Martian Martian
Mars in the Red Planet
and I like I said I didn't have any
goals or any of those things when I
first started streaming but you know
there was a group of folks that kind of
gravitated to each other we were in each
other streams we hung out with each
other and they were like you know what
why don't you lead leave the community
and I'm like and say what I'm gonna do
what you know and now we have a pretty
sizable group of us
and we're not just from America we have
you know folks that are Martians that
are in the UK folks that are Martians
that you know are in other places in
Canada you know it's it's a it's just a
really cool thing you know in our our
whole goal is you know inclusion
friendship and gaming and that's what we
do you know we're more like a family
than anything the the twitch link that
you have in there is that for a group or
is it an actual channel oh yeah yeah
yeah so it just hosts the folks that are
in in the community on there okay so
just mjd do you have any questions you
could play you're thinking of I know you
pretty much asked everything that I was
saying in the beginning or that I was
thinking of oh okay well I had I had a
question about when you when you start
streaming you said you you started off
with just like a regular PC and then you
kind of like evolved into other other
things right like you you ended up going
to like getting your Xbox getting your
graphics card you'll gato and all that
other stuff like did you feel like that
that was that was like a necessary thing
or you feel like it was so kind of a oh
oh well we well we got my husband I
bought it had got the Xbox one because
we wanted to play rock
we love rock band that's what was
response
I really wish they would make the The
Beatles Rock Band available for the
freaking Xbox like come on y'all let's
get it together you know and then I've
only had the ps4 since last Black Friday
when they had that really killer sale it
was like half off or whatever I bought
it then because everybody kept saying
you have to play Detroit become human so
I'm like okay I'll play it you know that
in The Last of Us
so so this year oh okay a little slow
story about Detroit become him and
because my wife is uh was a weirdo I
love her dearly
and she's in the chat and she's
listening and she'll she'll totally
understand this conversation she
actually got to the end of the game she
we actually borrowed the console from
her friend and she actually played it
non-stop and she is not used to the the
quick hand button combos for like
certain certain commands it's like you
have to hold the right trigger and they
have to hit like X and something like
you know things like that
that she actually got Oh zero one
percent um final like cinematic which
turned out to be a epochal another paw
collapse it was an apocalypse right a
holic Holocaust I'm sorry my apology
yeah yeah and she she she pretty much
was like oh no no and like she had to go
to bed after that oh yeah and she was
shoot and like I was asleep already so I
didn't know or see anything and she's
she ended up like telling me the next
morning and I was like you have to
replay that and yeah I did the one
playthrough so I didn't see that but
whoa that's deep
yeah yeah so that game has a lot of
different endings if you follow the past
and everything and some of them are
really really cool that one for instance
is pretty
but it's really amazing how you know how
it has so many different different
endings to the game and you said what
was that game you picked it up for The
Last of Us The Last of Us I I really
want to play it I've seen a lot of
people play it okay it's really good and
I only finished that one little over a
month ago some like that and played it
but you know and then to your question
about the elgato I have an elgato but I
don't have it set up so when I'm doing
my console stuff mm-hmm
I streams are bare-bones all it is is me
streaming direct from the console
there's no camera there's my all my
overlays are not there
there's no alerts none of that cold
stuff and you know but it was cut
thought it was interesting that you know
especially with the folks that have been
hanging out for a long time they were
like man those are some of your best
dreams just because they get to hear
just hear me react to stuff you know and
there's not a lot of flash and
everything in the way you know I was
like oh I didn't even know y'all felt
y'all felt that way about it they didn't
like how I react to the stories do you
have an internal all got owner or the
external one external I ended up having
the external 60 HD Elgato and I ended up
changing it out to get until I got the
internal one because the internal one
had greatly less latency but the problem
with it yeah it works out really really
well the only downfall is is that it
uses a graphics card slot so it's almost
like you lose a graphic slot but you can
end up doing that now what I ended up
doing was a nice nice job MJ you got
your Starbucks tickets we can screen
everyone can see that now thank you
Oh
the I ended up putting a stream box on
because of the division and I in the
first division because I play mostly PC
and I burnt through to 970 graphics
cards playing Division one so I ended up
getting the other computer so I get the
elgato and do the offloading and it
actually works out way better than I
could have ever dreamed for it and I
heard a lot of people were having
similar problems with division two when
they ended up playing it on PC so just
something just something to think of
when if you ever you know if you're ever
thinking of actually going full got oh
yeah because because it does it does do
great things but it actually it it's
very resource heavy right and the
external one does not deal with it
nearly as well that's from personal
experience for me other people probably
have had less problems but it's just
something to kind of think of so if if
nobody has any more questions I have I
have one more question for him if you
could live in one fantasy or video game
world what would it be oh my gosh that's
intense cuz I've played in some pretty
horrible worlds yeah a lot of a lot of
people a lot of people say almost worlds
are kind of in conflict like almost
every single video game world is in
conflict and all that other stuff but
you know those worlds like Marvel you
know being able to possibly be picked to
have superpowers or you know you never
know if one day you might wake up and
you know have like the ability to move
stuff with the force or using a wand and
like moving things like Harry Potter and
the those those kind of things I feel
like kind of outweigh some of them but
yeah that's true yeah some kind of cheat
what you think I think
pre pre-war rapture in Bioshock that
would be a cool place to live to live
underwater and you know and live like a
normal like a you know your normal city
I think that'd be kind of cool and also
I would say Old Republic Corellia before
the war because yeah in sweat or cuz you
know Corellia is beautiful you know and
it's really kind of like it's almost
like a city state kind of reminds me a
little bit of Khorasan but i couldn't
live on Khorasan it's too busy there's
there's no actual planet you know
walking on you know manmade materials
yeah so I think that'd be kind of cool
now
Bioshock is your would you say your
favorite game of all time yes
yeah I would actually you know a cold
second would be vampire which I really
love and that one has is another one of
those stories story games that have
multiple endings highly recommended for
folks who loves a good story or love
vampires what type of combat isn't that
game while I love the game I love it I
love the game that's you know a lot of
people they're like oh I love it and
then that doesn't mean you have to love
everything about it
I'm with you on that l-boogie that the
combat can be a little bit trying that
uh that target lock is a pain in the
butt I don't like it so I stopped using
it but it's mostly melee and then you
know you have vampire powers and stuff
but yeah what I said when I stopped
locking on to my targets it made the
game a whole lot better for me and the
map was frustrating was frustrating to
look at but the story itself and the
fact that all of the NPC's in the game
have a story they have a name they have
a voice that's amazing
because you don't see that in games at
all well I agree most games don't
have voice acting for every single
character yeah
and this one all the NPC's have a voice
actor and they have a some type of story
uh it's the only other one that I could
think of as Mass Effect I tried I tried
Mass Effect I tried I tried so hard I
wanted to I wanted to so bad like
everyone's like oh this is a great game
I can't tell you how many times I tried
to play the first one and every single
time I played the first one I would end
up just giving up trying to drive around
on the Mako like the Mako was like my
make or break I just I couldn't do it
yeah yeah and I'll you know and my
friends who are really big in the Mass
Effect they're like no you shoulda
played the first one first like but it's
the first one no but you should have
played the second one first like oh god
it's like you're that right in order for
them for a reason one's one and then
twos - okay if I had to play the sequel
to enjoy the first one what kind of
pointless they're you know yeah the
great agreed agreed
so why don't you uh why don't you tell
everyone why you know where you know
where they can find you like what's your
stream schedule you know all your plugs
and tell us all you know everything
about you know where we can find you
cool well thanks thanks y'all for having
me on your show I had a good time I'm on
Twitter and Instagram and Martian ket
underscore on Twitch
I am Martian cat without the underscore
hi stream on Mondays Wednesdays and
Saturday nights generally that at about
4:30 p.m. that's Mountain Standard time
then of course that fluctuates for
everybody else in the country because
Arizona doesn't change time we don't
switch you know my friend knocked he'll
say you know I live at the one tree time
zone because he's on the East Coast I'm
like whatever
that's amazing raid in no I usually just
do the story missions and I haven't done
any of like the big big missions of
division one or two because I could
never find teams your PC or ex-boxer I
play on PC well we'll talk after stream
okay we'll talk about the stream um l MJ
I heard you uh so uh so work where could
I find you my man you can find me on
Twitch at MJ's a boss yeah so when's
your return my return was last week your
return was last week yes I saw reruns
happening I didn't know you were you
were gonna be coming bad at night it was
that no during the week yeah that night
oh man keep-keep posts and guys gotta
check him out it's pretty funny and it's
October so I'm hoping I'm hoping he's
gonna play some scary games watching MJ
play a scary game is probably the most
entertainment I've seen in a very long
time because he reviewed a game and I
had to sit there and watch them and I
had to watch the video and edited forum
and he literally was like no no no no no
no no no that that doors gonna stay shut
that door seriously no no nothing for
for at least an hour and a half it was
like that I I just I was laughing my
butt off so l-boogie
where where are you I saw you came back
to - mixer started streaming somehow I
press the button and then one of my
friends text me is like you if you're
talking I can't hear you on your Street
almost three hours who are playing
destiny nope yeah well no no toward it
like like maybe
a half-hour that I didn't know how okay
yeah but um I finally got scheduled up
so if you go to my Twitter l-boogie oh
208 on Twitter you'll see my schedule
it's pretty easy I'm just off today and
then at 6 p.m. Eastern I'll be on mixer
at l-boogie
Oh too late so you guys come by there
and yeah make sure you guys hit the like
button looks like left but yeah hit the
like button please please say you enjoy
yes yes please hit that like button say
you're enjoying what we're doing here we
greatly appreciate everyone for coming
in and you know doing it doing their
thing and you know hanging out chats
been amazing tonight
we love you so like I was our last table
or you know table panel member I guess
you call him old school is a boss old
school as a boss Wow
I need to get some more so okay I'm
definitely tired old school styles he is
he must be out doing something or passed
out because he's been doing nights he is
on Twitter if you want to go check him
out he has a a excuse me a YouTube page
called old school tuck talk he also does
a bunch of our tech related articles for
floors he gave me net so um yeah so
definitely do that
I am Snell doe SN a ly do I'm on Twitter
and discord and twitch every night 7 to
10 ish sometimes later depending upon
what is going on except for tonight
which I usually get on still and do a
little little switch action before here
greatly appreciate you know that's thank
you
Thank You cat Martian cat for coming and
talking with us I greatly appreciate it
it's been a fantastic evening I'm sorry
for my internet deciding to stop working
for no apparent reason I've I don't know
why that has happened they usually have
some pretty dang good it or not so no
worries no worries thank you so much
thank you thank you for Christine a
little late to I
I know you know I I try to try to get us
out of here at 10:00 but we you know
with the internet leavin kind of screwed
up my time for him so I apologize I'd
like to thank all the viewers time for
coming and I really appreciate you for
first you know for that chat going back
and forth please hit those you know the
thumbs up the likes and and hit that
subscribe button for us here at IO nose
podcasts you guys greatly appreciate it
the episode will be up on Wednesday
Wednesday morning so when you wake up
and you're just like oh good work the
episode will be ready if you want to
check us out I greatly appreciate it you
know downloading it giving us a good
listen you know it's a you know it's
it's gonna probably be a crunched down
version of this one all edit out the
depite being annoying with the internet
for everyone if you want to know when
our next guest is coming out when our
video over our video our podcast is
gonna be out live for everybody
we are part of table stream on Twitter
it is weird I know I apologize
everything else kind of just didn't work
as our name is Gerren honestly long we
also have an email which is called table
stream tape Wow round table stream team
at gmail.com if you want to shoot
questions there for guests by all means
do so we will we'll ask them for the
guests that are coming up and iron
alloys podcast is on at Sundays at 11:00
a.m. Eastern Standard Time
also Lords of gaming net check us out
for gaming news we put a lot of effort
into it we have a lot of people that do
a bunch of different things on there
MJ's got an article usually once or
twice a month I have an article up there
you know once or twice a month old
schools the same deal you know so check
us out I think he'll is also working on
stuff too so by all means check those
out thank you very much once again and
remember everyone dream big and keep
gaming thank you and